bring in Terry Gannon Golf Channel NBC
sports play-by-play host Golf Channel
and NBC Sports are giving you live
tournament coverage of the 108 open
taking place at royal Portrush live
coverage on Golf Channel NBC sports
today through Sunday round 2 coverage
continues today on Golf Channel until
4:00 p.m. Eastern Terry how are you
today dan I know Father time all too
well how are you I'm good if we were
getting the best shooters in Northern
Ireland today how would you do depends
how you define it I can stand there and
shoot you have to move at all you don't
have to do nothing on the court no you
don't know just that it's like a koozie
set shot I can do that
I'm in would you be the best on the Golf
Channel coverage team
I just don't think about that I think
Jacobson can play a little bit he might
be able to shoot I think I got him
though Billy Ray Brown now he's more of
a post player sands Sansa has got
nothing so yeah I'm good what about
Faldo does Faldo have any athleticism
aside from golf I think it's all about
this wing I don't think I'm gonna take
them out there on the court any time
soon
all right what do you make of what
tiger's saying here about father time
and how is this different from Tiger in
April you know I heard your comments a
moment ago I think they're right I think
he doesn't know and I think we don't
know I don't think anybody has a clue
any time he tees it up how he's going to
play right now because of the backhand
where he is
in terms of father time and what he's
been through
Roger Maltbie I talked to him he was out
with him yesterday and Billy Ray Brown
and and their take away from ty and
Tiger was talkative yesterday was
talking to a lot of people he was open
and it was more about being tight it
wasn't necessarily pain it was just he
couldn't get loose you know and it's
cooler over here it's relatively
speaking it was low 60s and then down
into the 50s it's not bad at all to play
but with where he is he had to take in
his mind the time off after the US Open
so how do you do that
stay sharp have your swing where you
wanted to and then you go out there and
it's it's cool and you
can't loosen up you just don't know at
this point yeah but and I was watching
the broadcast yesterday and Nick Faldo
said you know he didn't have high hopes
for tiger because of the weather there
that if this was a hundred degrees or
really warm like it was with Augusta
then Tiger gets looser sooner or doesn't
tighten up as quickly and with the
weather although it's not that bad he
said that weather would play a role in
this and maybe that's the case with
Tiger maybe this is just an aberration
here with just the British Open not
being able to prepare and you know the
weather not helping him get loose here
yeah I think you play better today the
swing looked better today he's not done
yet he's scrambling trying to make the
cut I know he's gonna get there I think
the cuts gonna get the two over because
I'm sitting here I've got to go back on
a little bit but were you we're told
we're gonna have like a downpour within
the next hour so it's it's gonna be full
effects pretty soon so you'd like to get
done before that but I think it'll get
tougher for the guys in the afternoon so
could go to two over but I as mice as it
was this morning I think he was he
command the first tee and even the first
swing even though one a little bit left
it looked better than it did yesterday
and he got loose quicker than he did
yesterday so I think I think Nick's on
to something and he just he can't put in
the time in between to go out there and
compete and so it's gonna have to be
that moment of magic or those four days
of magic which we saw which I got to be
on a site I never thought he'd win a
major championship again a year ago
being around him watching a move or try
to move and you know he shocked us all
at the Masters so it could happen again
sure more puzzling Rory's performance or
Tiger high leg Rory I mean but but you
know this you've been around the
greatest athletes in the world is and
you sit next to them and as an analyst I
sit next to Nick Faldo and I try to draw
out all right Nick take me into this
moment you know walking to their first
tee the nerves at an Open Championship
or walking up the 18th green but this
was a moment and this is an event that
none of them have experienced this is a
country for whom it means so much to get
this thing back here
with all they've been through and put on
an open for the world here in Northern
Ireland and all the hopes on Rory
McIlroy and for now a number of years
since they knew they were going to get
it how many times is he going over that
first tee shot in his mind I just think
it's too big you know for any man not
for him particularly I don't know that
anybody can really understand what was
light to go out there and try to compete
yesterday
talking to Terry Gannon Golf Channel NBC
Sports play-by-play host and of course
was on that 1983 NC State team under Jim
Valvano and of course also does the
Olympics with figure skating more fun to
hang out with Tara and Johnny or Jim
Valvano a little bit different you know
I'd like to compare the two entities and
V would get a kick out of that but yeah
in their own right I think interesting
as well listen there was nobody like Jim
Valvano walked into a room
took it over he was on 24/7 there was a
moment that I was ever in the room with
him where I didn't have to have my
a-game or he would tear me to shreds
and if you were within you know 20 feet
you better bring it or he's going to
just take you down with the conversation
in the width and slept about four hours
a night and was into everything
what it was was an English major was in
the business had investment would quote
the great poets and writers it has never
been anybody like Jim Valvano that I've
been around but also you know
revisionist history here do you do tell
people you know how much you scored or
you know what what role you played and
shutting down phi slamma jamma first of
all it was a charge Clyde Drexler
certainly I had my feet planted and a
little bit of a wraparound buckets like
tackle but that was okay back they say
that was legal back then the game has
changed a little bit and of course I
averaged 25 points per game but did you
when you look back on Valvano looking
for somebody to hug why didn't he have
somebody why didn't somebody hug him
he wasn't quick enough I mean first of
all yeah you know you got to be out
there quickly I don't know where
Wittenberg was dereck Whittenburg was
supposed to be the designated hugger he
was in charge of that I mean we were
doing our own thing I had to throw
Bailey you know at midcourt and I wasn't
looking for anybody it just happened was
it happened organically was was that a
shot by Wittenberg oh you're serious
oh I'm I thought now he said Pauley do
you have Wittenberg saying it was a pen
I have different articles from around
the game saying there was a lob pass by
Wittenberg for Charles yeah yeah yeah we
worked on that up before the game if we
get in this situation what we're gonna
do we're gonna take a 30-footer and lock
it up Renzo Charles with Elijah want
right there in front of ya uh-huh what
if you were playin some mileage out of
that though I will hand it to him what
about a shot clock with you guys
NC state versus Houston I'll pass on
that one
you think they roughed you up well a big
part of that game the second half is
number one the altitude and Elijah one
started to go to the B went to the bench
got the oxygen mask he was worn out so
guy Lewis in part because of that and
they had built a lead went to their
locomotion game as they call they they
slowed it down they went they took the
air out and that's when we started to
mow and we just kept sending them to the
free-throw line if there's a shot clock
they can't do that they had a bit of
talent on that team and yeah it might
have been a tough second half for us but
the thing is that year the NCAA allowed
you to play as a conference with a shot
clock and a three-point line so in the
ACC we had a 30-second shot clock and a
three-point line all year long so we
were used to playing with that and you
know we beat North Carolina with Michael
Jordan with that and Sam Perkins so it's
not like we wouldn't have had a chance
at all but I'll I'm glad we didn't have
in the championship game did you
regarde Jordan yeah only in a box in one
though oh you were the one on the Box in
Mullen oh yeah it was the one so I
didn't have to help I just I just face
card to here wherever you went you know
there this little guy I'm sure he's
frustrated as hell can't get away from
me quit looking at me was he talking
trash even back then yeah he was good
from the start yep do you ever bring it
up with Jordan you know about I don't
know you see but you have to see him at
golf events it's the conversation about
college basketball NC State and North
Carolina are about golf well I for
example i'm leaving a club house one
time having played and i'm walking to my
car in the parking lot and this car with
tinted windows pulls up and the window
goes down and there's this voice that I
hear NC State sucks and it's Michael and
he puts the window up but up but here's
the thing and here's the idea you know
what it's like to be Michael Jordan
within about 15 seconds his car was
surrounded by kids and it took him about
20 minutes to get out of the parking lot
so it's it's good to be Michael but it's
tough as well I would imagine I'll leave
you with this you get two picks on who
will win the Open Championship I get two
yeah I'll give you two okay I'm going
Brooks kept out on a limb there but
anybody who does not pick kept should be
just dismissed out of hand and Tommy
Fleetwood okay
I like Tommy Fleetwood 7-under for under
today cutting he's in the fairway every
time I mean yeah I got a feeling
Westwood would be an unbelievable story
he's within one right now I guess see
now I know I'm going beyond my - but I
think he now could do it but I'll go
I'll go Fleetwood and Kefka I have Eric
van ruin as one of my picks very nice it
was a sneaky pick yeah with the joggers
on today he wore the joggers yeah look
but then I took Matt Wallace that that
hasn't gone well I got John ROM Xander's
softly
any Pepperell Oh that'd be great if
Eddie wanted do you remember his
interview last year yeah late night out
at Carney's he said he was he was
hungover yeah oh yeah he said I had no
shot toys right no it's kind of hung
over and well I didn't expect to shoot
67 now I got a hang around see if I can
win this thing
Terry thanks for joining us have fun
we'll be we'll be watching all right Dan
take care thanks for having me that's
Terry Gannon Golf Channel NBC sports
play-by-play host for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app